thinking of upgrading your setup but
don't know where to start the Corsair
K65 plus wireless keyboard and m75 air
mouse have got your back and here are
three reasons why the m75 air mouse is
only 60 G or about 2 oz in Freedom
Units with a battery that losts 100
hours and cor says quick track buttons
and precise as hex sensor you're in for
a poning good
time Hots off all the switches on the
K65 plus wireless keyboard to make it
truly yours the one we got comes pack
with Corsair rid which has three pins if
you want to use your own switches grab
the switch and keyc cap pull it from the
box and get to work it's about switches
of up the five pins also you can use a
keyboard for both Mac and windows just
switch it up with a slider at the back
the K65 Plus Wireless not only looks
sleek but performs like butter with two
options for wireless connections ultra F
slip stream Wireless with a 2.4 GHz
Dongo or Bluetooth you're guaranteed a
wirefree space without sacrificing
performance so which one are you getting
first tell us